since the committee last met in April
the pace of job gains has picked up and
labor market conditions have improved
somewhat further inflation has continued
to run below our longer-run objective
but some of the downward pressure on
inflation resulting from earlier sharp
declines and energy prices is abating
the committee continues to judge that
the first increase in the federal funds
rate will be appropriate when it is seen
further improvement in the labor market
and is reasonably confident that
inflation will move back to its two
percent objective over the medium term
at our meeting that ended today the
committee concluded that these
conditions have not yet been achieved it
remains the case that the committee will
determine the timing of the initial
increase in the federal funds rate on a
meeting by meeting basis depending on
its assessment of incoming economic
information and its implications for the
economic outlook let me emphasize that
the importance of the initial increase
should not be overstated the stance of
monetary policy will likely remain
highly accommodative for quite some time
after the initial increase in the
federal funds rate in order to support
continued progress toward our objectives
of maximum employment and two percent
inflation